the g20 you will this will be one of the
last times you will you will see Varrick
Obama as you will know there is an
American election underway and as you
will know there is a there is a choice
in that between Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump who would you rather have
at the other end of the telephone if
there is a geopolitical situation Donald
Trump or Hillary Clinton do you have a
feeling at all I would like to work with
a person who can make responsible
decisions and implement any agreements
that we reach their last name doesn't
matter
of course it's necessary for that person
to enjoy the trust of the American
people one just have the desire but also
the political will to fill all those
agreements therefore we'll never
intervene do not intervene and try not
to intervene in domestic political
processes we will closely monitor what
happens and wait for the election
results and then we will be ready to
work with any administration it itself
once that can I just can't just push you
on that back in 2011 you you um you
accused Hillary Clinton of seeking to
trigger the protests that you were
facing in Russia at the time and by
contrast when I look at I was just
looking at some of the things that
Donald Trump has said about you back in
2007 he said Putin's doing a great job
in 2011 he praised your no-nonsense way
next year he said you his new best
friend thanks to who said you were
outsmarting the Americans they said
you're good ratings together I could go
on and on like that but if are you
really telling me that if you have a
choice between a woman who you think may
have been trying to get rid of you and a
man who seems to have this sort of great
affection for you almost bordering on
the homoerotic you were really going to
go for
you're not going to make a decision
between those two because one of them
would seem to be a lot more favorable
towards you
[Music]
you know I essentially already asked me
a question I'll reformulate it again in
different words we are ready to work
with any president of course say that it
depends on how radically future
administration is if somebody says that
they wants to work with Russia he will
welcome it and it's someone as you said
although it may be a forceful station
wants to get rid of us that will be a
completely different approach we will
survive it and it's not clear who has
more to lose of an approach but I thing
is I have repeatedly seen the
anti-russian card played during domestic
political campaigns in the stage I think
that it's a very short-sighted approach
at the same time they send us all sorts
of signals from all sides it actually
things are just fine in previous
administrations that's the way it was
during the campaign we will restore
everything later you know it seems music
it doesn't flow amid the level of
responsibility that lies on the
shoulders of the US I think that all
this should be more dignified calm and
more balanced as for the fact that as
for the fact that someone is criticizing
us you know criticism is leveled at us
by mr. Trump's team as well the premier
for example one of the members of his
team said that we paid Blake Elia that
Russia allegedly paid money to the
Clinton family by some foundations
Meiko idiom what's that does that mean
that we control the Clinton family it's
of course I don't even know where bill
spoke and through which funds the
process so both one side and the other
side are using it as a tool using it as
a tool in domestic political struggle
and that's better when you meet
obviously what someone says that they
want to work with Russia we will welcome
it regardless of what last name that
person has see one last question on
Donald Trump some people say that he is
too volatile to be an American president
you are you are you you would be happy
with him an American president in the
same way as you would be happy with
Hillary Clinton in that role you know we
can ask for the American people are
wrong with all the shock tactics of not
only one but the other candidate they
are perfusing shock tactics Majesty in
the wrong way - the possible they are
smart they are very smart people they
understand which partners you need to
impress with so that the voters of
United Doodles understand feel and
listen to them we purchased will usually
is directly Stimac signors that Trump is
focusing on the traditional Republican
electorate people with average incomes
the working class a select group of
entrepreneurs and people that support
traditional values mrs. Clinton is
focusing in a different part of the
electorate is trying to influence them
in her own way so that's why they attack
each other in some cases I wouldn't want
us to follow their lead release news
premier Tucker can you do I don't think
they are setting the best things are
covered
that's the u.s. political culture we
have to just accept it as it is
pretty cocky America is a great country
and it has earned the right that nobody
outside should interfere with or comment
on so answer your question for a first
time we will work with any
administration in the venue president
will win the support of the American
people if of course they want to
cooperate with Russia